y saben cómo se haga uno cuenta que está
en problemas en la vida
cuando no has cumplido los 40 años y la
lista de doctores en tu teléfono supera
la de cualquier otro nombre eso es que
eres hipocondríaco
tengo 51 años ya lo voy a cumplir padre
de tres hijos
y director de cine publicitario y
fotógrafo
fue operado del corazón a los cinco años
por estenosis pulmonar
eso es una falla o digamos una estrechez
en la válvula pulmonar por lo cual me
operaron durante ocho horas sacaron el
corazón 15 minutos repararon la válvula
y lo volvieron a poner en su lugar
mi infancia adolescencia y parte de mis
momentos fueron totalmente normales
hasta que un día llegando a mi
apartamento en bicicleta en bogotá que
vivía en la primera cosa de 79 casi me
da un patatús
cuando llegue mi señora me vio tan grave
que me dijo que porque más bien no me
hacía chequear el corazón
mira cómo estás
yo creo que lo mejor es que saquemos un
seguro de vida
la verdad el comentario me estaba como
ofendiendo un poquito
pero después de unos minutos me acordé a
una frase que me decía mi papá
cuándo
ella perdón me acordé de una frase que
me decía mi padre
ah no
después de unos minutos
perdón después de ser rechazado por los
doctores
en más de tres seguros de vida ahí sí me
empecé a preocupar
lo que fueron
y la sangre que debía ir a los pulmones
se estaba volviendo el corazón en un 70%
y ahí me tocó
meterme en una cirugía del corazón
nuevamente
las primeras preguntas que me hice
fueron
porque a mí qué va a pasar con mi
familia
cómo van a vivir sin mí
pero después de unos minutos me acordé
de una frase que me decía mi padre
cuando tenía 12 años más o menos
y se convirtió en una de las frases más
importantes en mi vida
al hecho pecho
literalmente
al mes de nacer martín nuestro segundo
hijo
me operé del corazón
lo que iba a ser una cirugía sencilla de
tres horas se demoró seis
cuando el doctor salió a dar parte a mi
familia mi señora y mi madre recibieron
al doctor
no sé cómo decirles esto pero el niño se
puso malo quito
hay que seguir en el niño
eso sí la cirugía fue todo un éxito
se volvieron a la sala de espera sin
saber que les habían dicho y cuando mi
padre regresó a averiguar que lo que
había pasado
resulta que la válvula pulmonar por la
cual
me estaban operando había colapsado
hemos dicho había hecho que el corazón
colapsara una vez cerrado el pecho y
esto corre a animarme volver a abrir y
volver a poner todo en su lugar
la recuperación fue una de las
experiencias de las experiencias más
difíciles para mí hasta el momento no
por el hecho que me hubieran abierto el
pecho como un marrano
sino porque no podía cargar a ninguno de
mis hijos
y aparece una magdalena la depresión
post-parto fue espantosa
pero la verdad es que no podía creer que
estuviera vivo
dos años más tarde
me llama mi mamá
mi hijo no le vaya a contar a nadie
despertar el llamado a toda la familia
obviamente
pero a su hermano andrés le descubrieron
cáncer un cáncer complicado y tenía que
empezar tratamiento rápidamente
yo en estos días venía con una gripita
que no se me quitaba y con un ganglio
inflamado en el cuello que la verdad no
se estresó un poquito
y me opera en poco tiempo
un consejo
nunca manden ni a su señora
ni a su madre ni a su suegra
a que les den el diagnóstico de cómo les
fue la cirugía
con un tarrito en la mano mi suegra
llamo a mi madre no es clarita eso le
fue divinamente aquí el doctor me
entregó un tumor para que lo manden a
hacer una biopsia
tumor felipe pero si el que tiene que
hacer es andrés
dos hijos en menos de dos semanas con
tumor con cáncer
mi madre se iba enloquecer yo creo no
hacía sino decir que ni porque hubiera
matado una monja
el primer día que fuimos de visita al
oncólogo no siento a mi señora ya mí
y el doctor nos dijo su cáncer es súper
agresivo
si usted se quiere dejar morir perdón es
súper agresivo pero responde muy bien a
la quimioterapia si usted se quiere
dejar morir
no va a durar ni un par de meses
le mete el pecho y sale eso rapidito
la verdad la frasecita mencionaba como
conocida así que pues nos fuimos para
eso
aquí les presento a dos de los que
estábamos con cáncer los otros dos lo
que tienen son herencia de calvicie
y de acá a mi vida pasó de ser una
novela o un drama a una película de
ficción
dos años más tarde me tiene que operar
de la válvula pulmonar pulmonar
nuevamente esta vez porque la
quimioterapia al parecer la daño
al año siguiente mi hermano andrés
repite cáncer
y por esos días a mi padre le
diagnosticaron cáncer de colon pero el
muy avispada mente se quedó calladito
porque no quería preocuparnos en la
familia ya que teníamos a mi hermano en
esas
y seis meses más tarde después de que
nace a mi hija juana
yo repito cáncer nuevamente les presento
a juana y mi ganglio
y de acá mi vida pasó de ser una
película de ficción a un comercial de
televentas
cansado de esas quimioterapias que te ha
molestado tanto ya no aguantas una
cirugía del corazón más te tenemos la
solución por la compra de tres cirugías
de corazón abierto y dos tratamientos
para el cáncer te regalamos
completamente gratis un inolvidable
trasplante de médula
sí señor escuchaste bien totalmente
gratis aprovecha ya esta increíble
oferta y baja esos kilitos de más que
tanto te estorban
hace 6 años me diagnosticaron cáncer por
tercera vez esta vez a la altura de los
pulmones y ya no me salvaba
de un trasplante de médula si la segunda
cirugía del corazón fue complicada el
trasplante de médula se ganó el premio
ahí sí la vi peluda
es más les podría ser un té solito nada
más para contarles esa experiencia
según las enfermeras solamente dos
personas habían podido salir de ahí
de la clínica antes del mes y yo me
saqué el segundo lugar
28 días después de haber entrado a la
clínica
salí con 8 kilos menos ni un solo pelo
en el cuerpo y con unas ganas de vivir y
de ver a mis hijos que no podía con
ellas
literalmente volvían a hacer
yo creo que lo que más me ayudó
definitivamente es que no estuve
completamente aislado de mi familia
afortunadamente la doctora nos dejaba
tener o me dejó tener visitas conyugales
a este lo que yo llamo sexo seguro
seguro no le van a dar ganas de nada
la verdad que capacidad la de mi señora
yo ya hace rato me hubiera abandonado es
más no hacía sino decirle a mis padres
que le devolvieran la plática porque es
que le hayan entregado un producto
defectuoso o que lo cambiaran por una
mejor estado pero como dice el título de
película
no se aceptan devoluciones
pero esperen hay más
si no quedaste satisfecho con nuestra
espectacular oferta te regalamos un kit
completo contra la hepatitis c crónica
sí señores hace dos años me
diagnosticaron con hepatitis crónica y
saben que la culpa la tuvo el corazón
según mi cardiólogo
me la pegaron a los cinco años por una
transfusión de sangre
pero la verdad es que se convirtió en
una de las noticias digamos de las
noticias más importantes que me han
dicho en mucho tiempo
y saben por qué porque según estudios la
hepatitis c crónica
es la causante del tipo de linfoma que
me dio a mí
la verdad siempre me ha preguntado cómo
hago para aliviar o como he hecho para
lidiar con todo esto
y siempre he dicho que nadie nos enseña
a vivir la vida
y menos a cómo vivir las enfermedades
yo sé que hice trampa porque a los 5
años me operaron y la verdad yo no le
paraba muchas bolas a mi problema del
corazón pero sé que las enfermedades no
me definen
pero si han hecho parte de lo que yo soy
hoy en día
aprendí de las enfermedades
aprendí a vivir con ellas
lo que sí es que nunca dejé
que las enfermedades se convirtieran en
mi vida
la verdad es que siempre he pensado que
no hay mala no hay nada malo con estar
enfermo
a todos nos pasa
el problema es que hacemos cuando
estamos enfermos
cada quien hace o cada quien vive sus
enfermedades a su manera
a quien hace de su culo un florero como
diría una tía mía
pero por favor
no utilicen sus enfermedades como una
excusa para mendigar lástima
eso es muy feo
ahora tampoco es que la vayan a [ __ ]
contra todos los enfermos a decirles no
prescriben es que usted no tiene nada o
sea mejor dicho de que se queja si no
mira felipe como está
aunque las enfermedades las padecemos
nosotros los que las sufren son los que
están a nuestro lado
y ahí es donde tenemos que ser muy
cuidadosos
la verdad es que sin importar sin
importar qué tan graves han sido mis
enfermedades
en cierta manera siempre las he visto
como una gripa
hay dos eventos en mi vida que cambiaron
por completo mi manera de pensar acerca
de las enfermedades y no me sucedieron a
mí
cuando tenía 15 años más o menos a mi
madre le diagnosticaron con cáncer de
seno
se hizo su tratamiento y empezó se hizo
su cirugía y empezó su tratamiento en
houston porque no confiaba en los
doctores en colombia ya que dos años
antes un tío se había muerto su hermano
por un cáncer mal diagnosticado
mi padre siendo asesor en siendo asesor
en mercadeo y publicidad hizo lo que
cualquier publicista haría
un curso express de cómo aplicarle la
quimioterapia a tu señora en la casa y
no morir en el intento mi casa parecía
droga la rebaja
durante todo un año mi padre le aplicó
la quimioterapia a mi mamá y faltando
tres semanas para poder seguir a su
chequeo final
mi padre le dio por hacerse un chequeo
ejecutivo disque para hacer deporte con
los hijos
cuál fue el resultado pues según me
cuenta mi familia
el doctor llama a mi padre a la casa y
le dice un orden necesito que se venga
para el consultorio ya porque según sus
exámenes usted tiene seis meses de vida
6 uat
de inmediato cogieron para houston dos
semanas más tarde se llevan a mis
hermanos no a pasear propiamente
sino acompañar a mi madre porque ya mi
papá había organizado todo para poderse
traer el cuerpo en caso tal de que él no
sobreviviera a la cirugía
para hacer la historia corta estando
allá mi padre se hizo otros exámenes y
faltando un día para su cirugía
se dieron cuenta que todo había sido un
error en la forma que le han tomado los
exámenes en colombia
y literalmente mi padre vuelve a nacer
también
el segundo evento sucedió un mes antes
de que naciera juana
recuerden que les haya contado que mi
hermano andrés estaba en quimioterapia
por segunda vez
pues estando en una de sus guiños de
refuerzo junto con mi cuñada maría
claudia
reciben una llamada del colegio
para informarles qué
lucas y sobrino
tenía un dolor de cabeza intenso
de inmediato suspendieron la quimio y se
dirigieron al colegio
estando aún con la enfermera del
teléfono
se darían cuenta que lucas
habría colapsado
y que nunca más escucharía su voz
su risa
o sentir su amor en abrazos y caricias
lo que fue declarado muerto el 13 de
febrero del 2009
en la clínica principal de pasadena
california por un aneurisma cerebral
no hay enfermedad sufrimiento más grande
que perder un hijo
con qué derecho me voy a quejar yo en la
vida cuando por un lado mi hermano
pierde a su primogénito
y por el otro lado nos regalan a una
hermosa bebé
disfrutemos de nuestros padres mientras
están con nosotros
pero sobre todo no desperdiciamos ni una
sola oportunidad
para decirle a la gente que está a
nuestro lado en especial en nuestros
hijos
cuando los apreciamos
cuanto los amamos
porque no hay garantía que el día de
mañana vayan a estar con nosotros
no desperdiciamos nunca una oportunidad
así
sean agradecidos con la vida
yo lo estoy
nunca me he sentido especial
pero si muy afortunado
no solamente por tener una familia así
sino por todos los chances que me han
dado en la vida
por eso sonrían
siempre va a haber alguien que está peor
que ustedes
dejen de quejarse
la vida es para vivirla
yo sé que todo el día nos podemos dar
contra las paredes
pero nosotros somos los que podemos
decidir seguir adelante
obviamente la ayuda de una familia puede
ayudar mucho
si no lo haces tú nadie más lo va a
hacer por ti
así que es nuestra decisión
si tienes un problema y tiene solución
para que se preocupan
y si no tiene solución
y saben que al hecho pecho
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]